Who should replace Daniel Craig as James Bond?
One creative fan has a pretty good idea.
Fan art depicting Henry Cavill as the superspy
has surfaced online, and it's good enough
that if Hollywood execs hadn't considered
casting Cavill in the role before, they're
probably mulling it over now.
The image comes to us courtesy of digital
artist Jakub Maslowski via his Instagram account.
It's stylish as all get-out, and that's because
Maslowski used his top-notch photo-editing
skills to alter a poster for the 2015 action-adventure
spy film The Man from U.N.C.L.E., in which
Cavill starred as the charming secret agent
Napoleon Solo.
Maslowski was evidently inspired by a yet-unconfirmed
rumor that surfaced in September of last year
that claimed Cavill was being eyed to replace
Craig after next year's forthcoming as-yet
untitled Bond film.
For that matter, Maslowski isn't the first
to have this idea.
Fellow Photoshop wizard BossLogic also took
a crack at Cavill as Bond shortly before the
rumor started making the rounds.
Both fan edits definitely have us hoping that
Cavill being up for the part is more than
just a rumor.
The actor is, of course, best-known for portraying
Superman in recent DC movies.
He held down the role in 2013's Man of Steel,
2016's Batman V. Superman: Dawn of Justice,
and 2017's Justice League.
After that team-up film fell far short of
box office expectations, studio Warner Brothers
was forced to radically rethink its approach
to its DC properties.
Rather than continue building a singular,
interconnected world like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, Warner and DC went back to the drawing
board with a more filmmaker-driven approach
focusing more heavily on standalone films.
So far, the results have paid dividends; this
year's Shazam!, which largely paid lip service
to the established continuity, scored with
critics and was a modest box office hit.
Meanwhile, the upcoming Joaquin Phoenix starrer
Joker is already garnering early Oscar buzz.
But as a result of the recalibration, characters
that were less warmly received by audiences,
like Cavill's Superman, were sent back to
the drawing board.
For Cavill, this means that he should have
some time on his hands, if he wants to jump
into yet another iconic franchise.
Of course, it's not like the star is just
sitting around waiting for the phone to ring.
He'll be holding down the lead role of Geralt
in Netflix's upcoming, highly-anticipated
live-action adaptation of The Witcher.
He's also attached to star as Sherlock Holmes
in Enola Holmes, which will see Stranger Things'
Millie Bobby Brown appearing as the titular
younger sister of the legendary detective.
But few actors would sneeze at the opportunity
to play 007, and if the stars line up right,
the 36-year old Englishman could potentially
hold down the role of 007 for years to come,
just as Daniel Craig has.
The blond Brit has made a fine Bond, admirably
filling the superspy's shoes in four films
before agreeing to come back for one more
round in the physically taxing role.
The upcoming Bond movie has had its share
of bumps in the road on the way to screens,
but sneak peaks released by director Cary
Joji Fukunaga promise a rollicking, globetrotting
sendoff for Craig.
It's doubtful that we'll get any official
Bond casting news until after the final Daniel
Craig Bond flick is released on April 8, 2020,
but until then, this image should help to
give fans, executives, and casting directors
some serious food for thought.
Cavill is a gifted actor, he certainly looks
the part, and he's British to boot.
Thank you, Mr. Maslowski, for creatively stating
the obvious, this man needs to be the next
007.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.